i know we're going to have some wind in
southern nevada skies are nice and clear
out there we've got that early light the
sun is not quite up yet but it's just
about ready to pop up over the eastern
horizon that was a look over the west to
the spring mountains so parents if
you're getting the kiddos ready for
school now we've got clear skies a few
places with some breezes but we don't
have the wind yet and then temperatures
generally in the mid 40s this afternoon
coming home from school good sunny skies
low 60s and we'll have those breezy
winds there are already some wind
advisories issued for areas of southern
nevada i'll go over those in a second
we'll look for sunny skies highs in the
low 60s all the way through the weekend
breezy to gusty north winds today
through saturday in many areas of
southern nevada and then wind advisory
for las vegas tomorrow on friday 10 a.m
to 7 p.m bitterly cold air over the
northern plains rain across the
southeast turning to snow and freezing
rain check out these numbers
fargo minus 20 minneapolis minus 10
rapid city 3 degrees below zero oh my
gosh that's cold so they've got wind
chill warnings up there in that part of
the country and then winter weather
advisories for the east coast as this
rain is turning into snow and freezing
rain and then also down in texas they've
got some snow east of el paso headed
towards areas like austin to san antonio
through the day and into tonight so wind
advisories have already been issued and
are in place today
until four o'clock for lake mead lake
mohave and all along the colorado river
valley and then reissued again starting
tomorrow at 10 a.m through saturday
afternoon at 4 p.m all these other areas
of southern nevada southern nye county
las vegas other areas of clark county we
have a wind advisory tomorrow as i
mentioned 10 a.m to 7 p.m so we'll get
winds tomorrow could be 35 40 miles an
hour today up to about 25 that's
generally enough to put some trash out
on the roads and blow a few lightweight
objects around your neighborhood so be
careful 62 with sunshine tomorrow those
rougher winds are going to mess with
high profile vehicles and put some
bigger debris out on the roads and such
so please really be careful and watch
out turn your sprinklers off don't waste
water on these these windy days it
really is wasteful and then through the
weekend things calm down on sunday next
week a little warmer in the mid 60s a
couple of days